hello and welcome to this presentation
on the journey of a sample through an
automated lcms
ms workflow my name is robert wardle
and i'm a senior scientist at waters
corporation
where my role involves the development
and support of applications
on our lcms ms systems and i also
focus on automating these workflows
so today i will go through why you would
want to focus on
automation for lcm sms workflows
we will take a look at the waters
automation portfolio
and then it will go on a journey of the
sample
through this workflow before finally
looking at an example
for a panel of steroid hormones which is
an
application on progestogens and
androgens
once a sample is received into a
laboratory for lcm sms analysis
the first thing we will need to do is
perform some form of sample extraction
and the reason for this is that we need
to remove matrix interferences
this helps to increase signal to noise
by reducing chromatographic background
noise detected
in the mass spectrometer the result of
this
is an increase in analytical sensitivity
and provides
better more consistent quantification
sample extraction also reduces
variability associated
with matrix effects more specifically
iron suppression and enhancement effects
this provides more consistent data and
increased robustness of the lcms system
through improved column lifetime and
therefore reducing
costs as fewer columns will be required
replacement
it also reduces downtime associated with
cleaning of the system
and its components as the sample being
introduced to the system is much cleaner
there is also the benefit of
concentrating the analytes of interest
particularly those which are present at
low levels that can be difficult to
quantify
of course sample extraction can be time
consuming and laborious
and i know i have certainly had some
long days in the lab where it felt like
my hand has fallen off like armies
it's also prone to human error
especially when
there are more complex extraction
procedures required
and transcription errors are also
possible such as when manually typing
results into a limbs
this is why waters has focused on
automation
and looking at ways to improve the
workflow from sample receipt
through to reporting a results back into
a limbs
to minimize these problems
the evolution of the water's lcms
workflows started in the 2000s
where at this time and earlier sample
extraction was performed manually
generally with small batches of samples
analytical systems were hplc with tandem
mass spectrometers
such as the waters alliance and quattro
micro
and informatics was only really used to
control these systems
there was no sample tracking performed
with no limbs connectivity
or automation if we then went forward to
the 2010s
sample extraction was mostly still
performed manually
but was moving to larger batches and
having some liquid handling robot
functionality
analytical systems had moved on to uplc
with more sensitive tandem mass
spectrometers
allowing for faster run times and the
analysis of more complex analytes
also partial sample tracking was
possible with the introduction of the
tcam file converter software
but there was still no lims connectivity
so now let's let's focus on our current
solutions
and then take a more in-depth look at
how each of these
can be applied to the lcms workflow
we have split products up into three
categories based on sample throughput
volume
the labs running a lower number of tests
products such as the
andrew alliance pipet plus which are
electronic handheld pipettes
can provide a simple to use smart
pipette system
to help improve prepare accuracy and
minimize human error
if solid phase extraction is performed
then the auto specialist can improve
flow control
when drawing samples through and
diluting from the spe plate
with automated pressure gradients
the next step up into medium volume
workflows looks at the andrew alliance
andrew plus
liquid handling robot which automates
parts or all of the sample extraction
process
allowing for the analyst to perform
other tasks whilst samples are being
extracted
and then we come on to the higher volume
workflows with larger liquid handling
robots such as the tcam
freedom evo series or hamilton star
products
which give the highest level of
automation to the lcm sms workflows
and have the largest amount of
flexibility
another very important part of the lcms
automation workflow
is sample tracking which helps to
minimize transcription errors
and this is where the masslinx lims
interface and file converter tools come
in
and these allow for connectivity between
the limbs
mass links which is the waters lcm sms
system
software and in some cases the liquid
handling robot software
and the role of these products is to
transfer information
such as sample id well position and
results
so now i am going to take you through
our sample journey
before we look at each of the products
discussed and how they fit into this
process
the journey begins with the request for
the analysis of a sample
multiple samples are typically batched
together for the same analysis prior to
their extraction and quantification
in the case of the pipet plus no limbs
connectivity is possible currently
and therefore once the lab is ready to
perform the test
the work list with all samples to be
tested is printed
and the analyst will retrieve these
samples and perform the sample
extraction
the analysts will then place the
extracted samples onto the lcm sms
system for analysis
a massive example list can then be
created by using the masslink slim's
interface software
which i'll discuss in more detail later
and with this the sample id from the
lims
is imported and the lcm sms method
parameters from a method specific
template are set
the analyst must then specify the well
position or vial position of the samples
as with pipette plus sample extraction
is still performed manually
and once this is done the sample run is
submitted
and lcm sms quantification is performed
the final piece of the journey is the
same for all lcms workflows
once the data has been acquired the
batch is processed in target links
access software by the analyst
they can check that all acceptance
criteria has been met
such as the calibration line correlation
coefficient
and qc sample bias being within the
allowable limits
target links also has features to assist
the analyst in this process
where data is flagged if it is outside
of the preset tolerance limit
the data is then reviewed and approved
before being sent back to the lims
using the masslinx lims interface
so how does pipet plus assist in this
process
and what is different when compared to a
simple electronic pipette
well they are browser controlled
electronic pipettes
meaning that the extraction method is
programmed into the one lab software
the analyst will then execute the method
and the software will guide them step by
step
through the extraction furthermore
the volume of the pipette is set by the
software automatically
and with all and with the simple press
of a button the pipette will aspirate
the reagent
and then another press to dispense into
the required container
which again is nicely displayed in the
software
and you can just about see in the image
shown
of course as a result of this you will
get improved lab productivity and
reproducibility
results
if we compare this to the android plus
for a medium volume workflow
the two are very similar however with
andrew plus
the sample extraction is performed on a
liquid handling robot
as opposed to being done manually which
should help to improve
day-to-day precision of results reduce
human error
and allow for the analyst to perform
other tasks while sample extraction is
taking place
again the journey begins with a request
for the analysis of a sample
with samples being batched together the
analyst then retrieves the samples
and either adds them to the deck of the
andrew plus
or transfers them into a 96 well plate
for sample extraction
along with all reagents and consumables
required
as guided by the onelab software
the extraction run will be executed and
once completed
the analyst places the extracted samples
onto the lcm sms system for analysis
the remaining part of the workflow is
the same as we described the pipette
lost
with a mass linked sample list being
created using mass
the mass link's limbs interface software
and samples quantified
data is processed reviewed and approved
and sent back to the limbs again using
the masterlink's limbs interface tool
if we take a look at andrew plus in more
detail
like pipet plus it is controlled by the
onelab software
providing an easy to use visual
interface to assist with the setup to
run
the extraction method and allows full
traceability of protocols
andrew plus has the ability to perform a
range of extraction techniques
such as protein precipitation solid
phase extraction
and liquid liquid extractions with its
small footprint allowing it to be placed
in a fume hood
the analysts will load the samples which
could either be
in sample tubes or transferred into a 96
well plate
add the reagents and consumables and
then execute the protocol
in the one lab software and then whilst
the sample extraction run is taking
place
the analyst time is obviously freed up
allowing them to perform other tasks
and our final sample journey to discuss
is for higher volume workplace
where a tea can freedom evo or hamilton
spa
or starlet platforms are used
on the t on the teak and liquid handling
robots
a batch of samples is loaded onto the
liquid handling robot
from a printed work list reagents and
consumables are loaded
and checked using laboratory sops
and the script is set to run
on the hamilton star or starlet systems
there is the option to compare samples
requested from the limbs against those
loaded onto the hamilton system
and to do this the masslinx limbs
interface will create a file
listing the samples for the analysis
required
the analysts will load these samples and
the sample tube barcodes are scanned
and compared to those listed in this
worklist file
any differences between the two will
then be flagged to the analyst before
the extraction room begins
the advantage of this is that it ensures
the correct samples are extracted and
analyzed for that particular analysis
on both the tcan and hamilton systems
sample tube barcodes are scanned
and tracked through the extraction
process and so the final location of all
samples are known
once the run is complete a file is
generated
with this information present
in the case of the t-can a file
converter is used to allow the sample id
and weld position to be combined with
the templates
containing the lcm sms method
information
to create the sample list in math links
however for the hamilton all information
can be generated using
hamilton's venus software and so the
file can be generated directly with no
need for a file converter
once the sample list has been generated
the analyst transfers the plate
containing the extracted samples into
the lcms system
and as with other workflows samples are
analyzed
data processed and reported back to the
limbs
so the hamilton star and ticonfrida
t kent freedom evo systems all have the
ability to track
samples through the extraction process
from the sample tube barcode
scanned by the robot as you would
expect many different types of sample
extraction methods are possible
depending on the deck layout selected
but the options available on each of
these sim
systems is almost endless and i'm sure
you could probably make some very
precise cocktails as well if you wanted
these systems also have the ability to
perform liquid level detection
which ensures that there is a sufficient
volume of sample
and reagents to perform the method with
the volume
set in the software today
these liquid handling robots give the
highest level of automation
for a water's lcm sms workflow
and to get the sample id and well
position information from the tcam into
a former that can be imported into mass
links
a file converter is used once the sample
extraction run is complete
the tcan evo wear software generates an
output file
containing the sample tube barcode and
final weld position information
the file converter monitors the folder
where this is saved
and any new files created are converted
to do this the software will take the
sample id and weld position
from the output file and merge it into a
method specific template file
which contains the lcm sms method
information
and this file can then be imported into
mass links
looking at the mass link slim's
interface in more detail
once drivers are created and set up in
collaboration with the lims provider
a connection between the two can be
established
to import data from a limbs which is
used to create mass link sample lists in
the piplus and android
workflows a message is received from the
lims for a particular test of a batch of
samples
from this the mass links limbs interface
combines the sample id
received from the lims with a method
specific
template containing the lcm sms method
settings
the analyst will then simply need to
specify the sample location
and submit the run for analysis
and as i've also mentioned the math link
sims interface tool
can be used with the hamilton system to
compare sample ids for a particular test
with the sample barcode scanned on deck
to ensure that the correct samples are
present for that
extraction run
and then once data is analyzed processed
and approved
the masslinx lim's interface can be used
to send data back to the limbs
almost all information that is present
in target links can be sent
where information is set up in the
software
and once a target links file is
processed and saved
it can be sent with the simple click of
a button
this removes any need to manually input
results back into a lim system
and therefore minimizing the risk of any
transcription errors
mass links and target links also contain
features to assist
in the acquiring and approval process
using masslink's basic security
and in this user privileged privileges
can be set for example groups are
created by an administrator
which is typically a lab director to
allow for different permissions
such as full system access for method
developers
and just run and process samples for
analysts
and using the windows operating system a
user account is created
and then assigned to a particular group
depending on their
training and job role
all actions that are then performed in
mass links are tracked
with an audit log being maintained
target links also has features to
require signatures and reasons for
changes
to integration for example and
signatures through reviewing and
accepting data sets
and so to summarize before i go through
an example
waters have seen that there is a need to
simplify the lcm sms workflows as much
as possible
and this is why we have tried to address
each of the bottlenecks
in the process from the request for a
sample analysis
right through to the reporting of
results back into the limbs
completing the circular sample journey
automating the workflow as much as
possible should help to improve
robustness and precision of the results
minimize human error and also minimize
transcription errors
so with my final few slides i just
wanted to go through an example
where we have used this workflow to
simplify the extraction and analysis
of a panel of steroid hormones within
our lab
and i think it nicely shows some of the
features that i've discussed
and also goes through a typical sample
extraction method for lcm sms
so for this testing i performed a
precision performance
experiment where i evaluated qc samples
at
low mid and high concentration levels
five replicas of each qc sample were
extracted and analyzed on each of five
occasions
along with a calibration line on the
hamilton star platform
analysis was performed on a water
security uplc
i-class c of otqs micro lcm sms system
and due to no limbs present in our lab
as we are not a production
site we use the limb simulator tool
to simulate this portion of the workflow
a test file was created using the
masslinx lims interface
which contained the method id
used to ensure the correct method is
loaded
and also a sample id information
this file was selected in the hamilton
method
as you can just about see in the top box
of the image
the file is also used for the system to
calculate the number of samples to
extract
and then the first available weld
position in the 96 well plate is chosen
which allows for partially used
extraction plates to be used
hamilton also allows for loading
instructions
which guide the analysts through loading
of the deck
and also barcode checking to ensure that
all consumables and reagents have been
loaded correctly
for example if the water reagent trough
had been loaded into position
two on the deck rather than position one
an error message will be received for
the analyst to change the position of
that trough to be correct
before continuing the run
all of these features are optional in
the method being displayed with a
checkbox as shown in the image
however it's also possible to lock these
down within the script itself
and here is just an example of a load
instruction from the method
where blue lights flash on the deck
image to identify the location to load
reagents and a window describing where
to load these reagents
and the minimum volumes required to
perform the extraction room
there are also lights that flash on the
front of the hamilton system
which display the correct tracks to add
the reagents
to so in the example shown in the image
above
you can just about see this will be on
track 14 of the deck
for the sample extraction of this method
we followed our application note
which is also available on the waters
website if you would like
further information following loading
and barcode scanning 100 microliters of
sample was transferred from the sample
tubes into a 96 well plate
where internal standard was added
followed by protein precipitation being
performed
the liquid handling robot mixed the
samples after each reagent addition
but centrifugation was performed off
deck
following this the samples were returned
to the liquid handling robot
and solid phase extraction performed
using an onboard vacuum system
once the extraction run was completed
the collection plate was transferred
manually into the lcm sms
for analysis and the mass linked sample
lists were created from the output file
generated directly by the hamilton
software
extracted samples were injected using
the acuity uplc
i-class ftn and samples separated
using an acuity uplc hss t3 column
with dimensions of 2.1 by 50 millimeters
and the vanguard pre-column detection
was performed
using the analytically sensitive xevo
tqs micro mass spectrometer
and the run time of five minutes
injection to injection
allowed for the samples the analysis of
12 samples per hour
once data was acquired it was processed
in target links
before statistical analysis was
performed using
analyze it in excel
the approximate hands-on time for the
analyst in this steroid workflow to
process
96 samples manually would take around
six hours to complete but utilizing the
described automation workflow solution
would only take approximately two hours
of hands-on analyst time to complete
allowing for other tasks to be performed
such as the
very important coffee breaks or even
lunch
so now let's come on to the results
concentrations of each steroid hormone
in the qc samples are shown in the table
when samples are extracted on the
hamilton across five days
total precision and repeatability was
less than 6.7 percent
at all concentrations for all of these
steroid hormones
showing the potential to provide a much
more precise
and robust workflow when compared to a
manual approach
whilst also reducing the risk of human
error and transcription errors
and so to summarize we have gone through
the reasons to focus on automation
where time-consuming and laborious steps
can be avoided
and human error and transcription errors
can be minimized
whilst also improving results across
days
with multiple analysts we have looked at
the current waters
automation portfolio for lcm sms
workflows
and taken the journey of the sample
through this workflow
before finally going through an example
for a steroid hormone
if you would like any more information
around what we have discussed today
then this can be found at warplus.com
forward slash clinical or alternatively
feel free to contact me on the email
address shown
and so with that i would like to thank
lab roots for allowing me to talk to you
today
and of course i thank you for your
attention and hope
you have found this presentation useful
thank you
you